[Applause]
we're going to do delta capital delta
greek delta which means the uncertainty
in a measured value of any physical
quantity and so for example i might
measure the size of this square and take
a ruler across here and say it's five
millimeters or half men no that's more
like five centimeters plus or minus an
error and the error gives you an
uncertainty in the measurement what i've
got here is an experiment that we do in
the first year in which little steel
ball bearings roll down a slope and are
collected in
in
channels which are emotionally equal
width so this is number one two three
four five six seven then this should
fall in the central one but because of
this being rough it's going to [ __ ]
about a little bit so i'll push it
through the hole and as you see it comes
down the slope it meanders to one side
or the other so i'll do several of these
and you'll see oh they're all going to
go in the same one
not quite and it seems as though by
magic they're all coming down there and
i haven't leveled it off but if i run
lots of these you'll see
that after a while some of them will go
to the left some of them will go to the
right
and you'll build up a distribution
all right so there are some
going to the right so i'm going to the
left
and when you've done enough of these you
can see that on the average it's
somewhere between six and seven is the
peak and a range from somewhere say at
six and a half
down to four and up to nine most of the
particles are in that region
unfortunately you can't reduce the
errors completely i'm imagining that
this is a proton an elementary particle
which is really very small in size and
i'm asking the question can i measure
the position of this particle as
accurately as possible
so what i would have to do if i were to
take a proton
shoved in the nucleus and measure its
position i would have to get something
like a microscope to see it magnify it
up to a larger and larger scale so that
i can actually see where it is and what
happens is that i have a wave coming in
a light wave
jiggling along and it scatters off this
particle comes up through the lens
goes through a whole thing into my
eyepiece and i can look down in there
and see where the particle is from the
light that was scattered off it and from
that
image you can determine the position of
the particle later on but you can
determine it
but there is something called the
resolving power of this apparatus which
says in effect apart from a geometrical
factor you can only measure this
position
to within a wavelength
of this wave coming in if this is a
wavelength coming in like this and
there's a wavelength of that sort of
size
then i won't be able to measure this
position to an accuracy of plus or minus
that amount so i'll try and make the
wavelength shorter and shorter and
shorter tinier and tiny and tinier so i
can specify that position more precisely
and i imagine i can do this again and
again and again and get this position as
accurately as you would wish
except that
light is not just a wave it has a
particle aspect to it it is one of these
strange objects that physicists talk
about which is a particle which is a
wave
so this particle of light comes in
and it has an energy associated and a
momentum which is inversely proportional
to the wavelength so as i'm making this
wavelength smaller and smaller and
smaller its momentum is getting bigger
and bigger and bigger so instead of a
little feather duster coming in just
tickling this thing and coming up here i
imagine this is a big wrecking ball
smashing into it
as the wavelength gets shorter and
shorter and shorter so as soon as i've
measured it and this photon has this
particle of light has hit this that's
disappeared somewhere else and the light
i see up here corresponds to a particle
which is no longer there it's moved off
it's got a huge uncertainty uh error in
its well changing its momentum so the
more i try to precisely determine where
this is at an instant as soon as i've
done that in the immediate aftermath of
that particle coming off its momentum is
completely uncertain i don't know which
direction it's scattered off this was
first enunciated by heisenberg so it's
known as heisenberg's uncertainty
principle and this idea of using a
microscope is heisenberg's microscope
and it's the idea that he came up with
way way back in 1927 after he'd invented
the mathematics that makes all this
clear people said that's obviously
nonsense and he kept
coming up with illustrations and people
tried to disprove his ideas but nobody
found a way around this